different organisms respond differently
to injury
axolotls can regenerate entire limbs
planaria can regrow heads from a single
cell
but if we get even a small skin wound as
adults like most other adults mammalian
tissue we get scars not regeneration of
the tissue but why how come some tissues
can regenerate While others form Scar
Tissue how was that decision mediated
and why ultimately would it be useful to
have this information
well that brings us to the item on my
head
reindeer also known as
Caribou I'm known for their distinctive
antlers like the ones on my head that
are covered in a soft velvety skin and I
use a fighting mating and display
the interesting point of relevance for
this video is that reindeer antlers also
have the ability to regenerate after
being damaged or broken
in this video we will talk through this
latest paper about Ranger regeneration
and the wound response
so it all begins with an observation
what happens if you induce a small 12
millimeter diameter excision or skin
wound in either the antler velvet or the
dorsal back skin of adult reindeer well
the antler velvet regenerates after 30
days with new hair follicles while back
skin forms a scar
the researchers then wanted to explore
the molecular basis behind this
difference
but before we get to that let's just
revisit some basics of the wound
response and I did just say Basics but
the repair of wounds is one of the most
complex biological processes that occur
during human life
but it's okay we'll just look at the
picture to get some idea so what happens
following tissue damage
well in response to the damage there is
the initial Recruitment and activation
of immune cells so you have inflammation
and blood coagulation to prevent loss of
fluids and to prevent infection of an
open wounds
secondly there is new tissue formation
that results from effector Cell
Activation one of the main cells being
fibroblasts that can mediate this
response
a fibroblasts are also involved in the
last stage of the extracellular Matrix
remodeling where you have disorganized
collagen being deposited by the
fibroblasts and the formation of scar
tissue the held region lacks normal skin
appendages so hair follicles and
sebaceous glands
so to break it down to three steps you
have inflammation some proliferation and
some remodeling
now that to me was a basic overview of
the fibrotic queen response
and the reason why fibrotic scar is bad
is that it impairs tissue function as
the features of the tissue like the hair
follicles and sebaceous glands do not
always reform
it therefore also diminishes the quality
of life and you have a loss of tissue
homeostasis
now the interesting comment they make in
this review article is that they predict
knowledge gained from studying organisms
might help to unlock latent regenerative
Pathways in humans which would change
Medical Practice as much as the
introduction of antibiotics did in the
20th century
I said that brings us back to the
reindeer paper where now I'll just break
down their main findings
so firstly we know that many cell types
are involved in the wound response so
one of the first things the authors
looked at was whether the composition of
cells looks different in both the Velvet
and the back tissue they did this by
using something called single cell RNA
sequencing so they looked at the
molecular signature of gene expression
found in different cells at these
different tissues and I found that those
in the Velvet skin wound had
functionally discrete populations of
fibroblasts so these cells that are
important for the effector response in
the wounds
by taking a closer look at what genes
were being expressed they observed
perhaps as expected that the back skin
fibroblasts expressed the
pro-inflammatory signature that
concluded the factors cxcl1 cxl3
while the Velvet skin cells showed
regenerative gene expression
characterized by the genes crab P1 MDK
ntmp1
so evidently there was something about
these velvet fibroblasts
but was it something that was intrinsic
to the cells or intrinsic to the tissue
so what they did next was they
ectopically transplanted velvet tissue
to the back skin and after 30 days of
this engraftments they induced the
wounds they saw little scar tissues
suggesting regenerative competence is an
autonomous feature of velvet cells that
is they still had the regenerative
effect even when they weren't in their
usual environments however this ability
was partially lost if the wound was
induced six months post engraftments
so while there's this intrinsic property
it was reduced over time
but given what they've learned from this
finding could they find a way to bias
the wound response to a generation over
fibrosis
so to do that they then realized a lot
of their single cell RNA sequencing data
that they got from The Velvet
fibroblasts and the back skin
fibroblasts and I looked at those that
were differentially expressed and those
that were core genes being expressed in
the back skin fibroblasts includes the
immunomodulatory cytokines csf1 and
cxcl12
so they then tested whether if
inhibiting csf1 and cxcl12 these
immunomodulatory cytokines could improve
outcome in a rodent wind model and while
following local inhibition
they could see enhanced skin
regeneration
so I've evidently cut out a lot of
information that was presented in this
paper
but the most intriguing finding is that
it seems that this fibroblast fate
decision as to whether it's going to be
fibrotic or regenerative seems to have
been made prior to the wounds even
occurring
I think this is interesting because
while I work with fibroblasts and
fibroblast that becomes senescent plus I
saw reindeer and regeneration and
thought the whole paper sounded pretty
cool and I like their approach and their
experimental methods but it does also
raise some follow-up questions how does
senescence factor into this the presence
of senescent cells are thought to
increase the rate of wound recovery
so arsenescent cells present in one
tissue and not the other
how was the initial priming occurring
how does it vary in other tissues as is
it's not just the skin where we get
fibrosis heart attacks result in the
formation of cardiac Scar Tissue you get
cirrhosis of the liver and you get
fibrosis in the lung I mean that said
the liver has got some regenerative
potential so understanding that response
in more detail could be important
anyway due to the similarity of the with
humans potentially there are some
lessons that can be learned to deeper
progress in regenerative Medicine by
further exploring this model
as quoted in his article a future work
defining the mechanisms by which
fibroblasts prime regenerative or
inflammatory gene expression
May reveal additional functional tools
to drive regeneration and reduce
scarring on human wounds as well as
inflammatory skin diseases like
psoriasis and eczema
so with that there is only one final
question to ask why do reindeers
subscribe to The Cheeky Science Show
well because they wanted to be the first
to get their Hooves on the later
scientific breakthroughs and because she
slays
anyway if you want to learn more about
limb regeneration then you should watch
this interview I did earlier this year
here otherwise Merry Christmas thank you
to my patreon supporters and thank you
for listening